there's and you decide to mute yourself
where have you
gone welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel we're having a bit of
a chat today a little bit of a debate if
you will or an argument if you'd like
the question for today's presidential
style debate is new Stargate needs Brad
wght to show run if it is going to be
successful I will be arguing for the
statement and the wrong Harris over
there will be arguing against the
statement
um he's young he doesn't know any better
and bless him hindsight 2020 what but
guys how are you before we get stuck
in doing well stressed but excited for
this one excellent excellent um right so
here's the format this is what we're
going to be
doing me and Harris are going to get a
two-minute opening statement where we
will not not um be interrupting each
other or trying to distract each
other let's see how that goes um we will
then have a series of about five
statements we're going to argue each
statement we will have two minutes to
uninterrupted argue each statement and
then a couple of minutes where our
Matthew will be mediating um again a a
little bit of a a cross action argument
whatever uh Matthew will be reading your
comments as well in that point we then
will have our closing
argument throughout the debate please
consider throwing up a j for me if you
think well if you've got any sense and I
am talking sense and winning the
argument or if I suppose you must throw
up a h occasionally just to keep him
happy meaning that you think he is
winning the argument and but if that's
the case you hate Brad Wright so I mean
like what I don't even know how that
could that I mean that's the core of my
argument basically if you believe Harris
it means you hate Brad so will be an
easy
one uh Matthew will be mediating the uh
discussion and he is in charge so I'm
gonna hand over to Young
Matthew thank you Jay thank you Matt
with one t by the way can everybody make
sure they spell it with only one t gets
really angry if you spell it with two oh
the the
swearing want
it okay sh shut up
[Laughter]
J go on then let's get
started
okay but replace that with Jay okay
we're gonna cck start this with the
first
question um or do you want to do your
opening statements first first we have
to do our opening statements first
please so do your opening statements
we're going to Kickstart with Jay and
his opening statement who is arguing
that Stargate does in fact need Brad
Wright over to you
Jay the key word I feel in this
statement is successful of course
somebody else could come in and show run
Stargate but will it be successful I
would argue that if I was paying for
this show and it was my money being in
invested I would want to give it the
best opportunity to actually work and in
that case you want Brad right the one
person that was always there during
three iterations of Stargate other
people came and went you know we had
Joseph M have Robert Cooper and so on
but the person that was always there
leading the ship leading the way was
Brad Wright he has the track record to
support what we're actually trying to
get here which is a TV show that is
still
Stargate how many times have we seen
failed reboots come along because a new
showrunner new creators new directors
have to bring their Vision to this
project and it just looks different they
have to put what they think the show is
rather than what it actually is Brad
Wright was the
constant always there the leader the
captain of the ship the one person that
even if he makes some changes to this
new show this new
franchise it will still feel like
Stargate um we do need his writing we
need him to be coming in and actually
writing episodes and creating a new show
obviously he's already written a pilot
but more than that we need his vision
and we need his understanding and his
knowledge of the exist existing show we
need his relationships with the actors
his understanding of the actors because
hopefully we'd get to see some of those
Legacy actors come back and who knows
them better than Brad Wright no one so
when new Stargate does return finally if
ever Amazon get off its ass the the
sensible option the least risky option
is bring back the person that is
Stargate if there's one person out there
that is
the man to lead this the safe Pair of
Hands that we need it's Brad Wright and
anything that Harris says to argue
against it is just idiotic but you know
he's young he doesn't know any better
bless
him fighting words fighting words from
Jay Harris would you like to counter
that with your opening
statement yeah so I will preface this
with I do adore Brad right I adore his
work he's an amazing filmmaker
television maker writer producer etc etc
etc but as Jay said to have a successful
show Stargate needs to evolve and it
didn't evolve with its third show which
he was involved with and that was an
attempt at Evolution but the attempt at
Evolution was caught with a stagnant
very stagnant formula as great as it can
be it was a very stagnant formula he did
s 1 SGA SGU how many people do we hear a
claimer about SGU all the time of course
Matt and I like to talk about it but
everybody else tends to poooo it a
little bit more than it probably should
be there's SGA the AR I mean uh Stargate
excuse me the Arc of Truth there
Stargate Continuum which shows what the
larger broader scale of the thought
process behind the television making at
the time
was and it just doesn't add up to what
equals a streaming show today let's just
be realistic I I guess I don't
necessarily think that Brad Wright
should showrun and or has to showrun
there are other people that are involved
with Stargate Peter deloise is the other
person who has been there every single
episode of anything Stargate ever he's
he's just as much Brad Wright as as Brad
Wright is besides the actual directing
and like production aspect of some
things
so as great as Brad Wright is he's not a
necessity I think that's where my
argument is going to be where we have to
dial in our realism our realistic and
we're going to put ourselves in a shoe
and the mindset of a studio here so
let's be real let's be realistic let's
not put our star eyed glasses and Rose
tinted glasses on let's do this
right that's what I
got very very interesting I'm not sure
that I agree that Peter deloise is as
much Brad Wright as Brad Wright but I am
just immedi and he joined like half1 but
yeah
whatever
who cares about facts he probably votes
mag
sorry this is a this is a political
debate but we're not talking politics so
one point away from
apparently I'm the only one who ever
follows the rules
for some of the
questions yeah we're going to kick start
with some of the questions so yeah I'm
running a poll at the same time the poll
is essentially just going to go
throughout this entire thing and it's
does Stargate need Brad rights yes or no
you can answer it throughout the
entirety of this live stream if you want
to change your answer because of any of
the arguments that Harris or J makes
feel free to do so and at the end we'll
have a pretty unanimous decision I
reckon as to who's one get into the
comments as well if you like what Jay's
saying put Jay if you like what Harris
is saying press h and if you like what
I'm saying just press M if you like me
mediating don't don't don't the sexy
masterb but let's get k kick start into
uh into the first question H we're gonna
switch it up a little bit we're gonna
have Harris start this one so the
question is new Stargate needs Brad
Wright to to showrun if it is going to
be
successful Harris over to
you so Brad wght is no no no no no he's
made an
error the first
is any new show if it is a continuation
needs Brad Wright you've just read out
the opening statement question oh uh
rewind let's K started with the first
question Harris you are going to be
answering this one first any new show if
it is a continuation needs Brad Wright
to involved to keep the cannon straight
over to you Harris is it is that the
right
question yes
I think I got a different order of C
questions uh all right uh wait so hold
up don't count this towards my minute
what which are we on I will start your
timer in in in five the first question
is the continuation
question Oh I thought the question was
new Stargate needs Brad Wright to
showrun if it's going to be successful I
got all mine order opening statement
question so that's the overall question
now have you never done a debate before
this is I have but you got to send
different yeah when you send it it says
question or opening statement not the
same thing that let me ask let me ask
the question again let me ask the
question again and then we can start the
timer all right all right any new show
if it is a continuation needs Brad
Wright involved to keep the cannon
straight
Harris not at all I
mean I got one for this one of course
that just threw me off uh but no
literally this one's the easiest one to
answer because there are literal shows
and while Stargate was going on there
were people that kept the Stargate Bible
up there's always somebody that is
keeping the Bible of the show going on
while the show goes on that is not the
showrunner not the executive producer
not the head person so as Brad Wright
was doing all this there was somebody
doing the Canon not necessarily for him
but as Brad Wright did it that person
was standing right behind him and
writing it down the every Studio always
has someone making a Bible for the show
it's just a fact of life you want to
talk about facts so
legitimately even before Brad Wright
like put the show out on air somebody
had already written down what was going
to be in there we don't need anybody
else
to
necessarily take exactly what that is
and and try to make it exactly what Brad
Wright would do in this we could have
what I screwed up there anyway uh
sorry my my my brain is confuzzled after
that last one but the point still stands
that there's always someone with the
Bible and we we really don't need that
for not a secretary Laura uh it's
literally just it's it's a guy that
keeps the Canon it's a Canon master I
don't think that's the technical term
for Studios but every Studio has a Canon
Master every show has a Canon Master
Mark Fergus and Hawk otby put together
their own Bible so who's to say somebody
else can simple there there we go that
was that was a bad one but we're we're
sticking with
it are you done yeah I'm winning this
doie because you screwed it from the
beginning is the hate clickers question
next okay let's go to Jay for his
rebuttal on the question that was asked
before Jay here we go there was 17 C
seasons of sg1 alone
214 episodes sorry the 17 seasons of
Stargate 214 episodes of Stargate sg1
alone to keep straight that is a lot of
story a lot of events a lot of different
villains a lot of different Heroes a lot
of characters to keep in
line what we don't want is the Star Trek
problem now with new TR over the last
few years one of the biggest complaints
that trekkies people that really love
Star Trek have had is that the new
creators don't seem to respect Canon to
the point where they have actually hired
people that they that their only job is
to look at previous Cannon and make sure
that new stories still fit what is has
happened before and to be honest they
still screw it up constantly and that is
the biggest thing that's divided fans
that the can just isn't respected
because the people that are running the
show don't really care about it they
care about the stories they want to tell
they don't care about Star Trek as a
universe now as Gators we do care and
actually one of the things that Stargate
has always been really good at is
respecting Canon and keeping it straight
if a new show comes along and doesn't do
that then that is going to turn Gators
off immediately and you're going to lose
your core audience now one of the things
Brad Wright talks about when he talks
about Stargate is that there are rules
you establish those rules early on and
this is what Harris is talking about
Brad Wright establishes these rules and
with the other creators they then try to
keep to those rules now Brad W talks
about a few instances where they screwed
it up and to be honest the odd mistake
here and there is kind of fun because I
mean even with Star Trek I enjoy
spotting the mistakes occasionally and
we'll argue about it is it a mistake is
it not you know know it's fun but there
is a line and when you start messing
with Canon on like an historical level
and I
mean is problem sounds up thank you I
thank you for making my point for me
again a couple times in there though
because you made it better you made my
point better than I made mine in there a
few times I appreciate
it well you you didn't well we're going
into the conversation but you made no
points out all because you the
question mediating the entire
conversation and the other person in the
conversation yeah
anyway let's move on to the next
question and let's be
friends for the love of God we're
supposed to discuss the last question
argue for a couple of minutes Matthew
yes okay
so times we got to tell you the same
thing right Harris obviously just
dribbled and made absolutely no sense
for two minutes so I'm just going to
start by making that point but he
actually said about the Bible and that
has there's somebody in charge of the
Bible yeah Harris that's that's right
why not Brad was the only anybody
writing an episode of TV one person at a
time one person at a
time yeah go on then I no I'm I'm just
continuing your own Point like if if
it's not Brad Wright making the rules
into decisions he doesn't write every
single episode it's literally whoever
writes an episode is making Canon and
Brad Wright either approves it or
doesn't at the end of the day because
he's the executive producer and that's
just his role except he establishes and
not just Brad let's be fair like Robert
coer they established the rules at the
beginning and Brad Wright's philosophy
is that you then keep to those rules but
it was Brad right that came with that
philosophy of we establish rules and we
keep to
them
but look what they did with Star Trek
then in new Star Trek where did that
ever evolve or did it devolve the that's
the difference that they never did that
with actual care you just got J.J Abrams
coming in there and made it a whole
action sci-fi movie that you could have
put any franchise name on instead of
Star Trek that could have been anybody
besides Star Trek too we need something
truly Stargate you know exactly my point
so why not have the person that actually
then created R em the first place r
emmer no because the rules for the
Stargate series are completely different
to the movie they if you're talking
about Evolution so you're saying it's
okay to cut the cannon and do that Brad
Wright
wasn't the rules in an hour and a half
movie or the rules in 17 seasons of
Television I'm think the rules in 17
seasons of Television
which oh you've only given us a two rule
on this now have
you all I'm saying is yes I think we
both agree that Cannon is important and
should be
respected person to do that is the
person that created the rules in the
first place yeah but he's not the one
creating the
rules M MGM clearly
was no even though MGM did get involved
in the Cason and messed around with
casting quite a
lot but they didn't create they didn't
get involved creativ creatively and they
didn't say like Brad Wright you this Z
thing it doesn't really make sense can
we uh change the rules on that Brad
Wright was the one that go in not
day-to-day things by any means but the
large actual formulaic rules of what's
going on like this is how you get to
make this episode of TV he has to
formulate that alongside what they want
him to do they're the ones making the
rules for him so at the end of the day
it's it's head honcho is studio and
that's I guess my ultimate point is
trying to put the realism back into it
and look at this from the studio
perspective that's all I'm saying
someone's been
drinking it's too early that's you Mr
jger oh
wish I did like the point Jay made in
there um that the Stargate series was
very what was an evolution on the
Stargate movie with the different rules
I thought that was a very very
interesting point and I want to take
that to the comments so I want you guys
in the comments
now such an
unbi
I am very un but Harris when you make a
good point I will I will point it out
you mean
that change that and anyway
continue let's move on to the next
question you
so next question good to see you hello
Carrie how are you doing
yes let's go on to the next question
with so many hate clicking YouTubers and
online negativity Amazon needs Brad
Wright to appease fans we're going to
switch it up again Jay you're going to
do it this time so over to
you we've talked about this on the
channel many times we've got the rings
of power problem and that I I think it
was emphasized by the rings of power but
to be honest we've seen it over and over
again you could also call this the
Quantum Leap problem that before a new
show comes out YouTubers trans it they
jump all over it they just destroy every
decision that's made along the way every
leak we see there's some
negative just just having a Goa and
destroying movies and TV shows before
anybody even gets to see them we saw
this again most recently with the echo
series that certain YouTube channels
smash it and then when they then watch
it they do videos like I was forced to
watch it and I still hated it well yeah
because if you hate something before you
watch it you're going to hate it what is
one way to take the wind out of the sale
of these people bring Brad Wright back
it's a simple it's an easy win how can a
hate clicker then start slagging off the
show that we love the response is always
going to be yeah but if Brad Wright is
in charge we've got some trust and
Amazon seriously have a problem with
this because when starget gets announced
that's really going to be only second to
James Bond from a level of like fan
reaction when they when they do the new
James Bond movie that's going to get a
lot of attention and when they do when
they finally announce Stargate that is
going to get a lot of attention they
need to get this decision right because
there are a lot of people out there that
want Amazon to fail and they're going to
want Stargate to fail just because it's
Amazon this is going to be one of the
biggest things they've done since
acquiring MGM for 8 and a half billion
dollars and it really really matters so
I would argue all day the easiest way to
get rid of a lot of that negativity is
have Brad Wright in charge because
simply put how do you argue against the
original
creative simple as
that Harris would you like to rebuttal
that uh rebuttal or or do my I guess
just my argument huh your your your your
statement your your abuttal yes
well I I
once again I love Mason Brad Wright but
he's not the original creator of
Stargate the TV show sure but anyway the
appeasement of fans just that whole
topic just just the question itself is
wholly unnecessary and that's assuming
just the question is assuming that
they're going to come in with something
quote unquote woke or something that you
don't like why do you think who
would why would they hire someone if
they've taken this amount of time
obviously they're not going the rings of
powers rout or they would have hired
somebody immediately and jumped on it if
if they didn't care about Stargate in a
way much larger than they tend to care
about these other shows they would have
done it a long time ago we've we've had
the time taken to develop it have people
come in and test Bibles out have Jordan
Peele come in here see if this works
they've had directors they've had people
come in here there's there's just
suggesting that fan appeasement is
necessary is kind of disgusting towards
the Stargate base that's saying that we
don't know what we want we don't know
what we need one person is the only
person that can tell us this and that
person wasn't necessarily the person
making every decision maybe the person
overseeing a lot of these decisions but
not making them you know the I I just
think the suggestion of appeasement is
thinking it it's coming back into this
with the worst mindset you could even
have and it's it's saying that we don't
trust Stargate at all I think we all
love Stargate that's why we're here
Stargate if they revive it has already
been set up enough
to to do what it needs to do uh Russ T
Davies isn't winning any popularity
contest for old school Doctor Who fans
so I just read that uh but but that
that's a good thing that that's a good
example to use someone coming back into
something and like maybe being popular
for a little bit and going down a little
bit uh for the appeasement of fans did
you want Brad Wright doing Stargate
Origins when stared Origins was
happening uh not Origins excuse me uh
start uh uh not Origins what am I
looking for SGU Universe right after
sgaa was canceled that's the appeasement
right there did you did you want SGU to
continue after SGA happened that's your
appeasement that that would be happening
again if
if I do like the point you've just made
about Russell T Davis and Doctor Who
because when you were saying that and
talking about old creators coming back
necessarily is it a good thing he's not
winning any awards right now for for
bringing Doctor Who back I mean he I
like it but a lot of people do not so
it's a very good point very good
different day and age I I've got a
couple of questions for for Harris
following that that that um gibbering
mess of two minutes um you're not the
original Creator that's a point you've
made a couple of times now um so um Matt
you're supposed to still be mediating
this argument part so why have you Bugg
It Off yes hello hello I'm still
here
somebody um sees a Model T Ford right
and then designs a Bugatti Veyron are
you really going to say that the
designer of the Bugatti Veyron doesn't
deserve any credit because they're not
the original Creator they oh well you
know they look they saw a model Ford the
Stargate movie and the Stargate sg1
series it's it's chalk and cheese it's
it's it's it's
significantly more compare the Stargate
TV movies with the Stargate movie only
compare the Stargate TV movies with the
Stargate movie there you go well no
literally that he made two Stargate
movies the complexity of the story for
starget issue okay Stargate issue one
was in I would actually say it's not in
some ways a follow on of the movie I
would say it's inspired by because it
was very very different so let's not the
original C the person that is the
creator of Stargate for me is Brad
Wright and Robert C Cooper they did all
the development work they're the ones
that established the foundation of
everything Stargate we love I understand
that but that's for you that's just
that's not how it works that's me
mentally that's how we all process it I
process it the same way but that's any
contract that's ever made with Stargate
is going to involve emmerick as much as
I I much prefer the series over the
movie Always and and will have if
there's a movie made Emer is there like
s he is tied inherently to the series
and to just brush him off even though
he's kind of brushed Stargate off a few
times to brush him off two wrongs don't
make a right I think we once again think
about it from the studio perspective and
not just from those Rosy tined glasses
of the fan because as a fan I'd love
Brad Wright to showrun I'd love Brad
Wright to do a lot of things but
realistically I don't know if it's the
next question or that I might be
throwing up a answer a little early here
so might cut myself off the next
question so so the question was with all
of the
negativity with with hate clicking
YouTubers does Amazon need Brad to
appease the
fans and I would say yes he does that
the about the negativity that YouTubers
and other people will bring to the
debate before the show even comes out
and I would say easy way to nip that in
the bud is have somebody like Brad
Wright involved I would say Brad Wright
is really the only person that can be
involved over
Robert Joseph MOSI Delise himself any of
the
others they're all important but Brad
Wright was the person that was always
there he was always the headman of of
Stargate always was but the point here
is then do you do you think the
negativity that YouTube will bring and
it will let's be honest as soon as this
gets announced do you think that doesn't
matter
how does currency
work currency is basically based on
confidence the more confident you are
the more valuable Commodities if if the
if the studio acts confident if we we
even suggesting that as a fan base are
saying that we're not confident in
Amazon making this we're not confident
in these people doing this and you know
there is a basis in that for rings of
power and Wheel of Time and stuff like
that with the people that like Wheel of
Time season one uh or didn't like season
one adored season two Amazon has shown
especially and particularly after rings
of power that they don't want to make
that mistake again and they are actively
as a studio really really really
actively trying to not let that happen
again or anything even close to that so
as a fan base that is is wanting the
sleeping giant of sci-fi to come
back I I just think it sucks that we
even keep suggesting that instead of
putting the positive spin on
and and acting like we're confident like
okay these people are taking their time
yeah we wanted it a year and a half ago
when we really started talking about it
but they're not confident with what that
was at the time and they didn't want to
give it to us in a a shell of what it
could be so I I want to say even if
we're not 100% like gung-ho like okay we
got rings of power we got Wheel of Time
we've had these other series before the
expanse when it moved to Amazon didn't
end up going the same way as it good as
it was
before but but they know all that I I
just think if we're GNA get a good show
we have to trust the people making it
and that's more than just what is the
evidence of when a show gets rebooted
what does the evidence say that when a
show gets rebooted and continued and
they bring back the original creators
they tend to be reasonably successful
when they
don't they're not let's be honest that's
the evidence isn't it and we're G Talk
questions that's the evidence but when
and where which which series are you
talking about because this literally
just dependent on the series it's
dependent on the Creator at hand it's
it's a very individualistic thing we
can't just blanket it like that that's I
think it's also it's it's it's just
irresponsible to blanket it like that
where other than Battlestar Galactica
that's been rebooted that's been
successful well exactly that was a
continuation Star Trek is the only one I
can think of that was that had a
continuation and it was rebooted and it
was
successful
nothing else has
been every other time any show gets
rebooted it
fails
X-Men
X-Men first an entire reboot well okay
well that's I'm just said Branch if you
want to stick TV we can go
TV next question
terrible go on then we'll go move on to
the next question because this is this
is flam
story let's move on to the next question
okay I I don't like this question I'm
going to read it out
anyway why would we trust Brad though he
bought us
SGU Harris you have the
floor so this is kind of where the I had
to cut myself off from answering this
question a minute ago where part of the
answer is the adherence to formula even
the what Stargate needs needs as as a
series or a film whatever it comes back
as it needs to grow from what it was and
not just because it's so many years
later or whatever uh it's because
there's a new audience there there's a
whole new audience to be tapped into
plus an old audience and as much as we
love that old formula we can't strictly
adhere to that same old formula that was
brought from sg1 to sgaa to SGU and SGU
as much as I do enjoy the show
the majority of the fan base does not
like it or or at least doesn't remember
it fondly
so they have that as the thing that
takes out I know you and I like it Matt
that's why I prefaced it with that uh
but but it shows that even whenever Brad
Wright and and and I love the guy's work
I absolutely love the guy's work but
he's very uh formulaic in his writing
and the way he show runs and that's okay
that's there's there's a place for that
but in these new new streaming day in
the new streaming day and age and with
the amount of uh significance that
Amazon and Prime are putting on Stargate
we can't go back to the old formula we
can't go back to is and travelers is a
decent show it's a good show but it's
another one that has a very strict
formula that it aderes to and we need
something that's going to I mean and and
there and Brad Wright did try to evolve
Stargate in Stargate uh I keep saying
Origins I meant to say universe uh from
sg1 and sgaa it is a different show but
it aderes to the same formula and that
formula wasn't able to evolve alongside
the show and it got everything canceled
not necessarily MGM did have a bunch of
stuff going on but it didn't help them
uh it didn't sway them enough to help
the show Z shows at the time so
essentially long story short I I Adore
Brad Wright I just don't necessarily
think
that the same people that think unfly on
SGU are going to love what he brings
into the next thing as well and uh you
can go watch Travelers and decide
yourself upon that
one because I love Travelers but it is
very formulaic and it's going to stick
to the same thing that it was so we
shall grow and
evolve is the
formulaic uh thing really a bad
thing for streaming what are your
thoughts what are your
thoughts hi too right I'm on record
saying I'm not the biggest fan of
Stargate Universe right out of the three
shows it's my least favorite um I will
always love it's still better than most
of the things on TV because it's
Stargate but it's my least favorite out
of the three but it was improving by the
end of the second series that was a damn
good show and the basic premise of
starget universe was still
fascinating Harris there said most
people didn't like St star Universe I
would argue that is not true it's
divisive don't get me wrong there are
people that really really didn't like
Stargate Universe they found it
boring I was one of them but there are
people that think it's genuinely the
best of the Stargate show that it's
their favorite iteration of Stargate
that it was yeah okay a little bit more
serious and Harris then againsts talking
about an evolution of the show that
needs to come back Brad Wright
understands that a show needs to evolve
the three different iterations of
Stargate were different all right SGU
and sorry sg1 in Atlantis had a basic
core principles were the same but they
were still different and SGU was
different again but the important Point
here even though it was different it
still was Stargate it still felt like
Stargate and that's the important point
that Brad wght is capable and he has
shown it that he is able to evolve a new
show but it still be the show we love
and MGM killed Stargate Universe not
Stargate Universe the viewing Figures
were still good that show would have
continued for Seven Seasons if it wasn't
for mgm's financial troubles and it
would have got better and better it was
already getting better and we would have
seen a show that I think would have been
just as good as anything
formul formulaic is a bad different
they're all so different where they
follow the exact same formula for 17
seasons of Television so different but I
love it I love it SGU is different SGA
okay SGA and sg1 I will I will admit SGU
adds Kos with the same we're very
similar SGU addos into the formula all
it does a spaceship instead of a command
no they no come on that in SG in in
Atlantis I will agree that there are
were certain characters you knew who
like the Teel character was and you knew
who like the Sam character was and you
know they they had a formula for the
show and they basically they made sure
the elements of that I think they
evolved it and they improved that
formula but yeah I will agree that SGU
no there's no teal character there's no
Sam there's no O'Neal there's no you
know that's they character what's his
name uh Ronald is is the te character
career are you kidding me that's that's
like literally are you he's literally
they they cast a guy of color for that
role like for the exact same reasoning
like I'm I'm sorry but like that's the
exact same character translated into the
third thing it's not original at all I
love it I do love it Great Character
great character but it is
literally Grio was mental that was kind
of the point of G you didn't know
whether he was going to go on a killing
spree or not Ronan T anything like G can
you not argue that tilk was also a
little bit like are
yeah Mur
everybody well maybe not the humans
brainwashed a few
times did gre's character have any honor
te is all about the honor yeah GRE had a
lot of Honor he had a really weird sense
of Honor but he had a very particular
sense yes but he had he to his
honor I do I do agree I do have to agree
with that he did have honor he was a
military man at his at his core it was a
psych and the whole reason he was in
jail was because he didn't agree with
some of the Command Decisions of his
Superior because he because it didn't it
went against his morals as a as a but
was the core character that's anything
like telk and now
Ronan yeah was like telk I can conely
see that that they took the formula of
Ronan of telk sorry and they they
changed Lots about that character but
that's can you not say they did the same
thing from Ronan to
Greer no
how because kria is a different type of
character he is ang R is a different
type of character than TI but they
literally took that formula and put it
there that's what I'm saying where he it
doesn't evolve there's a tweak but
there's no evolution of a character it's
the same character
move forward just like Joe Flanigan his
Shepherd is it's it's it's Jack
O'Neal they're just tweaks that's all
you know not a bad thing yeah um I think
um McKay was a character on his own but
he was supposed to be um but he was he
was the character that they created for
sg1 yeah he left out from yeah you could
argue there's no Sam character in
SGA yeah eventually m m is the Sam
character me he's a Sam character but he
he
embodies he was supposed to almost be
the opposite to Sam in some ways wasn't
he but he was designed in sg1 to be
Sam's opposite and then that carried on
into Atlantis because he whereas Sam is
very confident and everything else and
um you know Rodney's supposed to be
arrogant where you can't say that about
Sam so is he was always supposed to be
the yin and yang I always thought for
Sam um but you can argue maybe that's
why they did it he was the comic relief
a lot of the time in SGA
yeah which which you could argue is Eli
in
SGU um but I wouldn't argue that e Eli's
character was like anybody else so but
anyway if you've got there was a very
interesting comment that Eli was a tweak
of Daniel yeah I would argue that before
Daniel got like ripped and had a
P90 yeah but the thing about having a
formula though that works works is as
long as you're able to adapt that and
evolve it I I would argue we need a show
I don't want a modern show modern
shows they're not always great I want
you know the the the season three of
Picard worked because it was
oldfashioned in some ways or in the Way
It Was Written Etc that's what I I want
a Stargate show I don't want a modern
version of it that is that is actually
painful to my brain
you even you know saying that I'm not
suggesting have a modern show
necessarily I I'd like for it to be
made as it should be made and I don't
think that I think that should be
timeless I don't think it should I don't
think it should stick to Old formulas I
don't think it should form a new formula
I think it should just be what it needs
to be simply put I think the story needs
to come first and they not try to be
like okay well we're going to have 12
seasons of this we're planning on seven
of this no no no no you're doing one
season this first season has to be
successful don't make a formula make
something that makes sense to the story
needs that needs to be told if this one
season needs to be if it's 12 episodes
and one one half of the the first six
episodes are one Arc that really brings
us back into things and there's a four
episode Arc and a two episode Arc so be
it if the next season is 12 episodes and
it's four three episode arcs so be it
dribling now I want them to come up with
a a universe and I I want them to think
big I want them to think we're going to
get 10 seasons of this think think big
of course but don't jump the gun don't
jump the shark that's what I'm saying
think big I never said don't think big
I'm just saying you have to focus on
what is at hand before you can actually
tackle that stuff set things up set
things up I want is Amazon to go we
trust this and we are going to give you
like they did with sg1 when it first
came out we're giving you two seasons
guarant guaranteed
go and you know ideally I'd love to 20
episode Seasons go but then that's not
going to happen but you know that's what
I want I want them to see like let's see
and then after the first season yeah
we're doing a third crack on I want them
to have the confidence that they know
they don't have to chase ratings because
then I think we'll get a braver TV show
we'll get a better I like The Confidence
from the artist actually making it not
necessarily like well I I'd like the
studio to hire an artist that's
confident enough with what they're
making that they don't have to worry
about
that I've just looked at the time so
we'll move on but you're wrong yeah
let's move on uh this next
question it's a very short one um so I
don't know if you'll need two minutes
for this
one but I'm gonna give you two minutes
anyway I'm I'm feeling
[Music]
generous the question is no one else
it's not even a question it's just a
stat and You' got isn't this just the
it's a question that we took out because
it was the same question twice wasn't it
oh mind I was gonna say it's right here
so I'm gonna say
it right about this yesterday the
statement is no one else can show
run
j i well I'm going to put my hands up
straight away and I cannot argue that is
impossible for no one else to showrun a
new Stargate series because of course it
is and we've argued on this channel that
we know who that person should be or we
believe and that person is a fan that
person is potentially could even do
something better with it who knows but
the question again the core statement
was will it be successful and I'm trying
to say here that if you want a manager
to come in a captain for the ship it's
got to be somebody that doesn't just
know
Stargate they know it inside and out and
then you can bring in new creators you
can bring in new writers you can bring
in whatever you want to make changes
bring in fresh blood as long as you've
got that person at the top in this case
Brad Wright watching over and making
sure it's still the Stargate show that
we love you can bring in as many New
Visions as many new Styles modernize
anything you want as long as you've got
somebody up there at the top that has
spent the last 20s something years
thinking about Stargate and not just
that in 2019 MGM came to Brad and said
we're going to bring Stargate back and
we want you to write a pilot so he set
about thinking about where Stargate
should be now he's already done the work
in his head he's already figured out all
of the problems and it is do not kid
yourself that bringing this franchise
back is going to be easy because it's
not you want somebody that knows the the
the franchise inside and out that can
manage that can sit over everybody else
and make sure that the ship keeps going
in the right direction and that is Brad
right all day long hey if Robert Cooper
wants to do it okay I would be less
worried but Brad Wright is the person
and he's the creative genius really that
knows exactly how to do it because he's
been thinking about it for decades ding
ding ding ding
ding okay
Harris over to
you well thank you for answering the
question for me that he doesn't need to
showrun because there's many other
people that could do it that we already
have an entire Old Guard
of wrong paper hold up hold up this one
an Old Guard of Peter Jonathan Glon
Robert C Cooper Paul mly Joseph MOSI
there's six names right there that or
five names right there that we can just
jump on immediately and
and everything I've said does not mean
Brad should not be involved he should be
here in a fige or a James gun to the DCU
kind of role not necessarily as head
honcho but at least a consultant to a
high
degree but shoot you you've seen dozens
of interviews of people writing writers
of shows and Brad's invol included in
this is you see an interview they're
like oh yeah I forgot I wrote that oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's always an oh
yeah because they totally forgot they
wrote something because their eyes are
on the future and not necessarily what's
on the past I think a new showrunner
that has had time like I said to start
this thing hindsight is 2020 nobody
knows this show better than the people
that grew up with it someone around
Matt's age that grew up with this as a
child and knows this like the back of
their hand is someone that you should
have showrunning this not I I I Adore
Brad Wright he's not too old that's not
part of it at all but someone that is is
literally grew up with this and and and
knows it like to the core not someone
and I have to preface it over and over
and over but not I love Brad Wright but
he's gonna say oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
that's just what people in writer's
rooms do because they have so much going
on upstairs in their heads so let
somebody that has that hindsight to be
2020 bring that Bible note person up in
that thing and and let him make
something magical and have Brad Wright
there to oversee it have Robert C Cooper
there to oversee it have MOSI have Molly
have deloise have these people over
there to oversee it but to to pigeon
hole ourselves into this one person can
only do this we are insulting ourselves
Asom you even said it then oh yeah I
forgot I wrote that oh yeah I forgot I
did this that is the point Brad right
instinctually is Stargate it doesn't
have to remember everything he created
the bloody rules in the first place he's
oh are because the oaz are because he's
made something that typically oaz
because he realizes wait this doesn't
fit in Canon that's why you get an oh
yeah you get an oh yeah because oh wait
I either have to make this and form fit
it to Canon because of rules that I
forgot that I made in the past that's
what an oh yeah is an oh yeah is not
like oh I was reminiscing about this on
a Saturday afternoon smoking a cigarette
and I just happen to remember that I did
this on that and I'm going to put this
in there and then oh yeah is like oh
[__] I messed up and now I have to make
this make sense we need someone who in
there there is one point of your
argument I want to focus on you
mentioned someone my age should show run
why not
me I I didn't say anything against that
I in I mean obviously Brad rght is too
old to showrun a new show and this is
all he is four years younger than my
father and my father is in more shape
than most people my age and I'm almost
25 not even there yet so there ain't
nothing about you'll know why I made
that comment if you don't I it's a joke
don't kill me which is why I had to do
what I did he sends the scripts in on a
chalk and Blackboard by by Carri Pidgey
um but go on
Matthew are you finished Reb butling
each other do you want to move on to the
next yeah because he's just a cra
we're going for the last this is the
final final
question so let's let's do it right Brad
Wright is Stargate Amazon and MGM own no
o sorry don't own they what they do own
but they owe him for his previous
success he has earned the right to
showrun
again Harris over to
you are we looking at this one through
Rosie tlass classes are we being
realistic about how contracts actually
work and if you are contracted and and
have a studio putting something in your
hands versus you bringing something to a
studio
um I I don't know if I had to say much
past that there's Rosie in the glasses
and there's being realistic on this
one MGM is start I'll go I'm I'm happy
to you do have a minute and 30 seconds
left if if you
Amazon does Secular monk just said it
Amazon doesn't owe Brad Wright anything
and as much as we as fans owe Brad
Wright a lot of time Studios if you put
yourselves squarely and succinctly in
the studio
shoes they can they can chalk up a lot
of success to him sure but they don't
owe him anything they don't owe him a
penny we do as fans do we as fans owe
them a lot we we owe them a lot of our
time and love but if we're looking at
this as the people that are putting
Stargate into the world again from the
studios
perspective we just gotta be realistic
on that
one okay okay Jay over to
you hundreds of millions of dollars
Stargate is generated over the years
from gimm and now Amazon that's what
Amazon and MGM owe Brad Wright because
Brad Wright was the constant figure with
Rob C Cooper don't get me wrong they did
all of the development work for all
three
shows they were the people at the start
of the day going what is Stargate going
to be they established the rules they
wrote on many of the best episodes they
brought in and they were the people in
charge Peter deloise has been mentioned
several times who hired Peter deloise
Brad Wright who was there every single
day except for two years on Atlantis
other than that Brad Wright was there
all of the time leading this ship the
way we go
but the executive producer that he
was just
you please I'm muting him I've muted him
it's fine Americans always jumping in
um there be so many apologies up for
this right
anyway there is no respect in Hollywood
and Amazon have done this before four
again we talk about the rings of power
problem Peter Jackson how much were they
slagged off for not talking to Peter
Jackson with the rings of power TV show
when that came out and Lord of the Rings
they started a conversation and then
apparently according to Peter Jackson
they just went radio silent on him that
caused a load of grief and it lead to a
lot of the negativity towards the show
and again Amazon are doing it they're
not talking to Brad and people have
noticed we've talked about it on this
channel that people have noticed when
you've got somebody like Brad Wright who
is Stargate through and through who was
there all the way through 17 amazing
shows seasons of shows and then you
don't pick up the phone and make a
call it's show some humility this man is
olded okay where time is
up let's let's do the rebuttal then come
on Harris what have you got to say he
didn't say anything so what what's that
to
reot also the moderator hat is back on
and the moderator hat is actually a it's
a run skate party hat so type that into
Google it's the moderator
okay go on Harris i' muted you mate s so
what you said a minute ago was
completely deaf I mean like I knew I was
muted I was I was just moving my mouth I
didn't even say anything yeah okay I KN
there wasn't a point
uh should we
final
statements the what should we go to our
final argument closing
statements sure let's do it we can make
our points
there who wants to go first do we flip a
coin go on there yeah
okay who who Who's
Who uh the coin is flipped and J anyway
apparently I don't have a coin I don't
know why I said
it over
to
okay when right so Harris has made some
really no he hasn't made any good points
at all let's be honest he's made complet
he's been he's been he's just for like
the last 40 55 minutes in this video but
you know he's tried bless him but some
of the things he said in the start of
this video that the new series has got
to be an evolution that we don't want a
stagnant show and that you can keep
doing that all the way through I don't
care I'm not I'm not looking um he's
mentioned Peter deise over and over and
over again and he has said that we've
got to be
realistic and I am talking about this
from a realistic point of view this
isn't just about Rose tinted spectacles
this is about getting a show that is
going to actually be successful and Brad
Wright isn't over the hill he isn't out
of touch he knows Stargate backwards if
you bring him in he will run a show and
that's why I'm saying he's got to be the
show and he's got to be the person in
charge bringing New Blood he has shown
us over and over again that he is more
than willing to work with other creators
he's the perfect person to do this and
nobody else has got his track record
nobody else will appease fans like he
will and I'm sorry but appeasing pan
fans in the Modern Age is important
because negativity will kill the show
before it even
airs so yeah Brad Wright is not only the
right person for the job he's the only
person for the job and I hope he brings
in people like Rob Cooper I hope he
brings in pet deloise I'm not a massive
fan of Joseph MOSI but that's his
politics we won't get into that but
bring him in as well because actually L
starget Atlantis is probably my favorite
show so yeah bring these people on board
but just like the first three seasons of
Stargate Brad Wright has got to be the
top man now he always says it's a team
game you want a manager that is willing
to build a team around him and that's
what we need from Stargate we need the
right man to evolve this show yes but
for it most importantly to still be
Stargate and Brad Wright is the only
person that can do
it that's my fault
you stopped
sorry Harris over to you closing
statement
please
so you can say there aren't roson and
glasses and you can say there
aren't levels of realism but there are
whe whether we we want to acknowledge
them or not they're there
and while Brad is an amazing showrunner
he's an amazing amazing creative in
general he hasn't had a show on air in
the last five or six years the way
television's made has changed entirely
in the past five or six years what are
we worried about right now more so than
anything and everything AI that's going
to be huge they already put AI into
Stargate scripts that was one of the
things that probably brought AI to the
level of knowledge publicly that it is
now is the Stargate script was like all
right look at all these Stargate people
coming on to it that brought it to
millions of people who were like oh well
now ai is capable of doing something
like this and now they can go and talk
to their friends about
it let's be realistic times are a
changing I'm not saying no one has ever
said that anybody that made Star in the
past is too old or too out of touch or
anything of those sort they need to be
involved but it is a new world a new way
of making television a new way of making
television in a way that they typically
make films that's what I say when I say
it should evolve Stargate whether it's
on TV or in a in a movie format it
should feel film quality and and that's
something that we've never been able to
see even whenever we get a TV movie from
the people that have already made
Stargate in the past so have them on
there to showrun not showrun excuse me
have them on there to consult have them
on there as advisers but we need a new
new show new people new
audience it's it's have the Old Guard
there do not get rid of that old guard
that Old Guard is necessary all caps
necessary but if you want that sleeping
giant to wake
up it has to it's it's springtime it's
been in hibernation a long time you went
in and it was fall it's springtime now
it's time it's time for some new
growth simple as
that
you're M Sur that was more than two
minutes it felt like it was going on
forever you
like yeah it was more than two minutes
but it's fine it's fine it's
fine so we did we we we've had the
debate the debate is now over over the
course of this entire debate we've also
been running a poll uh with the overall
question of does Stargate need Brad
wght to make some guesses do you what do
you think the the uh outcome of that is
yes or no 70 7030 or 8020 I think it's
7030 in my favor I think and I've not
looked I don't know Harris is pretty
much on The Bard 79% saying yes Stargate
does need Brad wght 21% saying
no but you said need Brad Wright not as
Strow Runner specifically so that also
doesn't the question kind of could have
could have made that point at the start
it was the whole point well yeah but the
whole poll that's not the point of the
the entire debate can I just point out
I've not I am the moderator of this
discussion I put the poll up and the
poll means what I'm say it means damn
right uh I haven't been reading the
comments in this video and we've had oh
nearly 400 comments during this video
thank you so much guys I've not read any
of them F lot a lot of a lot of very
good comments they've been fun to read
we're gonna be going over to uh another
live in just a second and we're going to
be talking about the the debate as a
whole
um so come and join us over there in
just a moment but thank you to our hang
out J Jamie rxm and Harris M3 G3
mcgr boom CED but
yes
see